Одні їдуть, щоб сказати:
«А я був у Сковородинівці!»
Одні їдуть і кажуть:
«Яка тут благодать!»
Шрифт — це камертон культури,
це мистецтво «ледь-ледь».
Ти ледь-ледь змінив форму літери,
і ти опинився в ренесансі,
зробив якийсь розчерк — і опинився в Запорізькій Січі.
Для мене дуже важливий, для мого життя,
Сковорода, його філософія.
Сама територія — садово-паркова зона —
це в першу чергу пам'ятка XVIIІ століття
з унікальними старими алеями.
Головний символ Григорія Сковороди —
це коло, це вічність, це без початку і кінця.
І тому ще у XVIII ст., в кінці, коли зливаються
кошти Каразіних і Ковалівських,
поміщики і закладають ось цей парк.
Ось цією стежкою, встаючи о шостій годині ранку,
ой, пробачте, до сходу Сонця,
він ішов до свого улюбленого джерела.
Взагалі, вода — життєдайна,
йому давала фізичну наснагу,
і давала духовні сили, душевний спокій тим,
хто спілкувався з Григорієм Савичем.
І в ось цій прекрасній такій аурі, в благодатному місці
любив знаходити відпочинок Григорій Савич Сковорода.
І зараз ви чуєте як щебечуть пташки,
і яка приємна тут така прохолода будь-якої пори року.
Григорій Савич Сковорода у своєму листі до Ковалинського напише:
«Перебуваю у мого Андрія Івановича Ковалівського.
Земелька його — нагірна,
лісами, садами, пагорбами, джерелами прикрашена.
На такій місцині я народився під Лубнами».
Григорій Сковорода жив в епоху бароко.
Бароко — химерно, вигадливо.
І Сковорода писав так.
Він і зі словом поводився, ну так, як хотів, так і поводився.
Дуже багато їжджу по різних країнах,
де знаходжу різні проєкти, друзів, ідеї.
Так що можна сказати, що я — каліграф-мандрівник.
Зараз дуже багато можливостей використання шрифту:
від графічних проєктів, логотипах,
шрифтах фірмових.
Можна використовувати як в середньовіччі:
робити рукописні книги,
можна розмальовувати будинки, робити перфоменси.
Я багато до того працював зі спадщиною Сковороди,
був знайомий із великим дослідником
Сковороди Ушкаловим.
Він подарував мені скани його рукописів,
і я їх вивчав.
Я, як каліграф, вивчав як писав Сковорода,
які стилі в нього були присутні.
І оформлював його праці.
Наприклад, оформлював повну
академічну збірку його творів,
спираючись на його стилістику,
на барокову таку українську каліграфію.
Музей мене запросив зробити проєкт,
пов'язаний із афоризмами Сковороди,
які я міг би втілювати в каліграфічних плакатах.
І так, щоб цей текст, і цей сенс
жив у просторі саду та лісу музею.
Ми всі Шевченка називаємо пророком,
але, власне, таким є і Григорій Савич.
Його називають філософом любові,
його називають філософом свободи.
Народився Сковорода у Чорнухах на Полтавщині,
і з самого дитинства він тягнеться до знань, до науки.
То ж 12-тилітнього сина батько
відводить у Києво-Могилянську академію.
Навчатися потрібно було 12 років,
Григорій Савич, власне, і не закінчив
повний навчальний курс,
але дуже добре знав латину,
вивчив старогрецьку і староєврейські мови,
досконало вивчає німецьку, він знає італійську мову,
згодом вивчить польську і угорську мови.
Твори писатиме книжною мовою того часу.
А сам буде спілкуватися весь час українською мовою.
Віртуозно навчається грати на скрипці,
малій, великій флейті,
на бандурі, на цитрі грає,
на гуслях грає, на органі грає.
Він пише ноти.
Посилаючись на геліоцентричну систему Коперника,
Сковорода створить світ, три світи:
всесвіт, макрокосм, і невід'ємним від великого
є маленьке — мікрокосм, тобто людина.
І, власне, вся творчість Григорія Савича
і спрямована на кожну конкретну особу.
Коли говорити про особисті речі,
то вони загинули під час Другої світової війни
у музеї Слобідської України імені Сковороди.
І тому ми експонуємо свиту.
Вона в усі часи була однаковою.
Свита 18 століття.
Посохи Сковороди, каламар.
Оригінальний каламар із музею Києво-Могилянки.
На цьому інструменті Григорій Савич грав,
перебуваючи в Бабаях у свого друга
священника Якова Правицького.
А ось на тому годиннику напис:
«Од Григорія Варсави Сковороди
через Стефана Гричину. Щоб пам'ятали:
з усіх втрат — втрата часу найтяжча».
Тому, що вчив Сковорода — це дуже важливо:
це відчуття свободи, яка притаманна
українському народу,
і цю свободу, і прислуховування до свого серця
треба втілювати і в професійній діяльності,
як то в дизайні, у мистецтві, так і в житті.
Нічого надміру, тільки те, що потрібно,
тому що все матеріальне, власне, не охопиш.
І от я з цього приводу завжди посилаюсь на його фразу:
«Нині скіпетр і булава, утром вставши — худа слава».
Відповідно матеріальне зникає,
а духовність, вона залишається назавжди.
Та славний ти мій.
Шевченко ж писав:
«Григорій Савич із своїм нерозлучним собачкою
прийшов у Переяслав до переяславського сотника».
Так що собачка — це здорово.
Вона тільки кусюча. Як і всі.
Сковорода — веселий.
Веселість — це стан гармонійної душі.
Сковорода — аскет.
Аскети в нас які там?
Ну такі виснажені, такі...
А Сковорода веселими ногами іде по землі.
Сковорода радіє всьому, що навколо:
і зелена трава, і сонце, і дощ.
І все ж це — прекрасно!
Школярів привозять,
бо вони вивчають творчість Сковороди.
На вивчення творчості Григорія Сковороди
відводиться дві години.
Перший урок учителька розказує
коли народився, де,
і прочитала виразно «Всякому городу нрав і права»
або «De Libertate». На вибір. Ага?
А на другий урок попитала на виразність читання. Все.
І ніхто не сказав як потрібно любовно
ставитися до життя — найвищої цінності.
Ми сьогодні говоримо:
«От в Європі, значить, їхні цінності — це життя людини».
А в нас ніби це не цінність?
У нас це величезна цінність!
Григорій Сковорода був невід'ємною
частиною нашої України.
Невід'ємною. Невід'ємною тим, що вже говоримо:
священники не розуміли,
заможні пишалися тим, що в них був Сковорода,
тому що Григорій Сковорода —
це, власне, ну, надзвичайно оригінальна постать.
Колись казали: «Та на сьогодні Григорій Сковорода —
це, власне, тренд України».
Сковороду ж дуже багато знають закордоном:
серед філософів, серед учених, серед митців.
Як колись пишалися заможні: у них гостював Сковорода.
Сьогодні теж усі хочуть пишатися тим,
що у них теж бував Сковорода.
Власне, своїм духом, своєю творчістю
Сковорода може прийти до кожного,
і бути там, де його хочуть бачити і чути.
Він нам важливий для сьогодення тим,
що він прислуховується до свого серця,
і в цьому прислуховуванні відчуває свободу.
І ця свобода, вона не залежить від системи, від ієрархій.
І вона — така горизонтальна між людьми,
якби така толока на рівні країни.
Поєднання сердець і свобод різних людей
у справі відбудови і розвитку країни.
Чим би не займався Григорій Сковорода, він — філософ.
А що таке філософія за Сковородою?
Уміння бути самим собою.
І з самим собою вести бесіди.
Бути рівним собі. І шукати самого себе.
Якщо ми в своєму сердечку будемо
шукати прекрасне навколо,
а не затьмарюватися тим, що негатив,
ми будемо теж щасливими,
бо цього вчив Григорій Сковорода.